bonjour philippe bélair merci d'être
avec nous ce matin merci d'autant plus
qu'il est très tôt chez vous il me
semble au pas et justement de ces
restrictions à dents dans les antilles
est ce que dans un premier temps elle
vous semble justifié ces nouvelles
restrictions
écoutez la situation s'aggrave il ya
plusieurs rebonds c'est simplement dû à
notre avis à une mauvaise gestion à g à
mettre aux prises puis la parole sur vos
antennes et j'ai déjà expliqué pour nous
il ya une gestion dès le départ bon et
il s'avère que maintenant puisque la
situation s'aggrave et surtout puisque
les autorités ne donne pas de réponses
concrètes en termes sanitaires
nous sommes obligés nous sommes
contraints de prendre le taureau le tour
le plan ou même par les cornes et nous
adapter et accepter l'idée le nom pareil
on confinement sans fête où nous envoie
de l'eau puis s'agit tout simplement de
faire en sorte que certaines périodes
certaines tranches notamment de la nuit
vous avez dit de designers de 22 heures
19 heures - faire c'est de 19h à 5h du
matin les le couvre-feu est ce que
justement ça ça vous semble de justifier
cette ce nouveau enfin cette avancée du
couvre-feu
nous c'est justifié parce qu'en fait les
moyens ne sont pas mis ce si les moyens
sanitaires médicaux hospitaliers étaient
mis sur la table ce ne serait pas
justifié c'est justifié parce qu'en fait
l'hôpital ne répond pas à la crise
l'hôpital et comment il va le jeu est
encombré il ya embouteillage de patients
ici nous avons 69 15 x 600 cas pardon 69
malades et une quinzaine de rick de
réanimer alors oui de personnes en
réanimation
c'est un peu une gestion à flux tendu et
c'est ça qui nous inquiète c'est qu'en
fait mal vue et expériences malgré les 2
rebonds qui ont eu lieu depuis un an
nous sommes troisièmes voies vont les
autorités préfèrent gérer la situation à
flux tendu c'est à dire que vous avez un
litre d'eau à gérer avec un verre d'eau
voilà la situation
si je peux me permettre cette image
quelle est la réaction des guadeloupéens
quant à l'instauration de par
l'instauration de ce qu'on veut mais
comme vous l'avez dit à l'avancé de ce
couvre-feu de 19 heures deux vendeuses
de pardon de 19 heures au lieu de 22
heures
à l'époque c'est à dire que les gens
sont les j'accepte mais les gens sont
disciplinés gelé ça aussi je n'ai déjà
rose il est dit et je le redis je n'ai
dit je l' ai répété à m reprise les gens
acceptent les gens sont disciplinés bien
sûr bien sûr il ya toujours quelques
individus qui sont un peu à l'écart et
qui sont plus rebelles mais nous
craignons qu'à un moment donné les gens
en aient marre
et puisque vous savez que les autorités
encore une fois j'ai entendu mais les
gens sont on accepte ce discipline mais
il ya un moment donné où ça ça va pas
tenir ce 60e prochaine fois pas tenir
je pense qu'à un moment donné d'ailleurs
on a vu par dans la période de carnaval
notamment chez nos canaux
nos amis de la martinique qui a eu un
moment donné notamment au niveau de la
jeunesse où les gens ont manifesté ce
ras-le-bol et voila voila il ya un
risque effectivement que les gens en
aient franchement ras le bol alors jean
castex était en déplacement il ira quand
le premier ministre l'a dit la situation
s'améliore en métropole notamment avec
cette campagne de vaccination en parlant
de campagne de vaccination ou est ce
qu'elle en est exactement chez vous en
guadeloupe
les gens restent méfiants il faut être
clair à un peu comme en métropole les
gens restent méfiants et ici on est à
peu près à 8 ou 9 % de la population de
vacciner ici c'est essentiellement le
vaccin puisèrent et astrazeneca commence
à se mettre en place mais les gens
restent totalement méfiant vis-à-vis lé
dans la mesure où nous avons quand même
une culture du soin de la prévention les
gens pêcheurs auraient préféré à selon
notre analyse qu'il y ait cette
prévention plutôt que le choix
thérapeutiques qui a été fait d'eux des
récits massivement sur les accès
particulièrement des vaccins dont
personne ne sait exactement encore les
conséquences à moyen et long terme merci
beaucoup philippe bélair d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france encore
une fois merci d'autant plus qu'il est 4
heures du matin elle chez vous vous êtes
secrétaire général fédération santé cgt
guadeloupe merci beaucoup